i have a little project um that i'm so
excited you guys agreed to tackle
throughout the show
thank you so much and um like everyone
else in the world
i have a disaster of a junk drawer and
there's a reason it's a cliche is
because it's true and
i actually put it all together in a box
and i sent it to you guys
so i'm so excited for you guys to open
it and see what you're working with are
you ready
oh we're i'm ready all right there's the
box i put it all in there
and fedexed it to you guys okay yeah no
it's it's definitely there's some stuff
yeah we see some stuff and it's actually
the contents of a very typical junk
drawer
things that people don't have a home for
that they just
throw in yes you know chargers extra
remotes they don't know what a unicorn
squishies
sunglasses post-it notes
not a doll head just dull hair
yeah i'll tell you that
okay i'm so excited i can't wait to see
uh
how it all turns out how's it going you
know right now
we are sifting through other items we
want to make sure that we can properly
edit and categorize those are the first
pieces to the process okay i have so
many questions i'm like if there are
remote controls in there
like do i keep them or do i let them go
like chords your guy he's actually
belong to a thing that you need to turn
on maybe
i don't know i don't know interesting so
it's not like it's a project that we
need to address
it certainly doesn't need to take up the
valuable real estate of
a junk drawer right do we need the
remotes there probably not
especially if you don't know what if
they work i would put this in like an
old electronics bin you know the stuff
where you're like i don't know
maybe it goes to something but you don't
need it in your prime real estate
hmm see already i'm so inspired and all
i want to do is run home and make an
open electronic store all right i
will check back in with you what magic
manifested while
organizing um i'm so excited it's
actually my junk drawer
um what is the most important lesson for
diving into a project like this
oh you want to pull everything out of
the drawer
you got to take every single thing out
so that you know what you have
and you want to then edit out things
that don't belong in that particular
space we uh have a box full of things
for you that don't belong in your junk
drawer it doesn't mean you have to be
taken away or thrown out or donated they
just need to be relocated to the proper
space
yes that is often a misconception when
we do a purge and we edit it doesn't
necessarily mean that you're throwing
things away
it just means that you are moving them
to a more appropriate location exactly
again this is prime real estate we don't
need to have our old
maybe tv remotes maybe we don't even
know what they go to exactly
think about the space that it's going
into do you need something that you
don't even know
that you have in the most prime real
estate spot of your house
probably not ah ah
what happened look at that
yeah beautiful it's clean it's easy to
find and the things that you do want in
a junk drawer you know
extra cables to charge your phone you
know nope pads
batteries exactly sunglasses
are all here
that's why you're the goddesses that you
are
this is all we know how to do like let
us remind you that yeah
oh my gosh and yet you make all of our
lives better
and i who am literally on my knees to
you guys
in awe of the before and after and
i would love to know dear ladies
is there any home edit wisdom that you'd
like to leave
our you know audience with today
absolutely well again i we always come
back to you don't afraid don't be afraid
to start
you've got it to be good at organizing
you have to start somewhere so just
start and just remember to start really
small yes a drawer like this is the
perfect
place to start people are always tagging
us saying just got the home edit book
and now i'm tackling my closet and we're
like
no we told you start small we don't want
people to get
uh what we call like pantry paralysis
where you've taken everything out now
you don't know where
how to put it all back right so again
this is a perfect
place to begin absolutely and we love
using organizing products
in most of our spaces however that part
is very fun to shop for
don't get ahead of yourself that is that
comes later in the process
you don't want to buy things that you
don't know exactly what you're going to
end up keeping
so wait until the step yes unfortunately
there is a there's a process that you
have to follow yeah
it starts with the edit then it goes to
the categorize then it goes to
containment and then
the maintain which is again in assigning
a place a label whether it's
you know the rainbow or a sticky label
anything exactly
um may i ask really quickly if and i
know that there's a succession
that one should follow is there any
measuring
involved like did someone want to make
sure they have a measuring tape
i'm so glad you brought that up you know
what you want to absolutely measure the
space
before you buy the any sort of
organizing products yes
absolutely measure and don't forget if
you know yes you want to
do the length because you really want
the height
yes you don't want to get a drawing that
doesn't actually exactly
if you try to close the door it's very
frustrating to get home and have the
wrong size
yes measuring is key yeah clea and
joanna
i would love to continue to learn as
your humble student clea and joanna
try to pick up your copy of the home
edit workbook i've been carrying mine
around with me that's how attached i am
and watch get organized with the home
edit available only on netflix